four and a half billion dollars you're
not responsible for all of that was it
worth it well four and a half bearing is
a big number but in terms of nuclear
plant that's a fairly cheap plant you
know the other ones that are being built
will be seven billion and so it would be
a very effective asset for us it will
power seven hundred thousand homes
carbon-free at a cost that's below are
embedded cost of electricity today so
yes it's worth it should we rethink
nuclear in America now that this country
has access he just dropped four and a
half billion bucks but we could rethink
it no no for the future I'm not
suggesting we turn this thing on and
then shut it down right away I'm talking
about new capacity America's still a
growing country it's gonna need more
power now that we have access to all the
cheap gas from fracking should we build
any more nuclear plants I think we need
to build nuclear plants you know today
in the country nineteen percent of our
power comes from nuclear is the cheapest
the most reliable and by 2050 all those
plants are going to be retired it's
cheap before you factor in the cost of
but these are serious way storage waste
storage is more of a political problem
than a technical one we know how to do
this they do it around the world using
American technology so I really don't
think that's a big issue is certainly
not a big invite economic issue I was it
more of a political issue the
environment yes where you gonna put it
all the things with yucca mountain in
Nevada those are really political issues
not technically so from your perspective
what's more dangerous storing nuclear
waste or fracking in the Marcellus Shale
I think they're both safe you know the
EPA come out yesterday with reward that
fracking is generally safe if done right
we have had no issues in this country
with the storage of spent nuclear fuel I
think they're both safe if they're done
right well when will you be fully
operational I hope by the end of the
year it's been a while eric said 1973 we
started this we've really worked on at
Nerdist for the last four years so I
would expect at the end of the year why
is awesome sorry I just unstarred
updates then we'll get to the jobs why
does the startup date keep getting
pushed back well we started it the first
oil embargo happened actually I would
think I was in high school when it
started the amine recently like it was
you know it was supposed to be this
month in fact wasn't it now they
actually the range was somewhere between
june of this
in june of next year so we will be we
like to give ourselves a little room
here we'd like to be will be about
halfway in the range and December would
be a great christmas present force how
many jobs have you created people you
employ so we're actually employing less
people today we'll add people at that
plan but our business is shrinking and
so we've been employing less but part of
our job at TVA is to make jobs in the
region and if you look at last year in
this year we'll have made about 125,000
jobs and maybe 15 billion in capital
investment all driven by a very low
electric rate I know we have no time
left just what's your view on the US
economy giving your position well I saw
your job projections I think you're a
little bullish I think there's still a
lack of consumer confidence I'm not
going to follow your bet on the upcoming
horse race I think it's sluggish this
rough very hard to predict there you go
feel great singing good to see you first
friday in june no better day to talk
nuclear energy bill johnson he's the CEO
of the Tennessee Valley Authority